hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
packe heute ein typisch indisches brot
und zwar ist es namen brot es wird
später in der pfanne gebacken und
typischerweise wird es immer als beilage
zu hauptgerichten serviert das brot
besteht aus einem hefeteig mit etwas
backpulver und die zubereitung ist auch
wirklich sehr einfach ich werde es heute
auch ohne küchenmaschine kneten und
zeigt euch einfach mal wie das
funktioniert ich brauche dafür 500 gramm
mehl einen teelöffel backpulver einen
teelöffel salz zwei teelöffel zucker
einen teelöffel trockenhefe zwei
esslöffel warmes wasser 100 milliliter
milch 150 g naturjoghurt mit 3 5 prozent
fett und zwei esslöffel sonnenblumenöl
natürlich könnt ihr den teig auch mit
der küchenmaschine zubereiten aber ich
wollte euch einfach mal zeigen wie es
auch ohne geht
ich versuche jetzt zuerst einmal salz
mehl und backpulver wenn sich die
zutaten nämlich richtig schön verbinden
und das backpulver verteilt sich eben
auch gut im teig dann kommt es direkt
auf die arbeitsfläche und zwar als hügel
und da kommt jetzt in die mitte ein loch
hinein also eine mulde
da gebe ich das wasser mit dazu und die
hefe natürlich könnt ihr hier jetzt auch
frische hefe benutzen muss dann einfach
die halbe menge nehmen
das wird jetzt kurz verrührt und da
kommt auch direkt der zucker mit reihe
ich jetzt milch und joghurt und
idealerweise sollten die jetzt nicht
mehr kühlschrank kalt sein sondern ein
zimmer war
jetzt gebe ich die mischung auch mit
hier rein und verkneten erstmal alles
mit den händen
bevor dann später noch das öl mit
reinkommt
zum schluss kommt dann auch noch das öl
mit dazu und der hefeteig wird immer
besser je länger er geknetet wird also
mindestens acht bis neun minuten sollte
auf jeden tag geknetet werden
der hefeteig ist es schön gerd geknetet
und es soll jetzt nicht zu weich sein
aber auch nicht zu fest ich habe jetzt
auch nicht komplett ganze mehl verwendet
und jetzt soll ich ihnen zu einer publik
und muss ihn jetzt erst noch vor der
verarbeitung aufgehen lassen
dafür gebe ich ihn in eine schüssel mit
etwas mehl und bestreuen auch mit etwas
mehl und lassen an einem warmen ort etwa
30 bis 60 minuten aufgehen ließ das sich
verdoppelt hat und das mache ich mal ist
so dass ich den ofen auf 50 grad schalte
macht den ofen dann wieder aus und kühlt
das auf etwa 30 grad ab und das ist die
perfekte temperatur für den hefeteig
der hefeteig ist jetzt gut aufgegangen
und jetzt nehme ich eben direkt heraus
und daraus entstehende gleich acht boote
die teile jetzt so ein dass sich diesem
tag erstmal viertel und steht für teile
werden dann noch mal halt jedes
teilstück zu einer kugel geformt
damit ist die teigstücke gleich besser
zu den namen boden verarbeiten kann
müssen sie jetzt noch mal etwas ruhe so
etwa 15 minuten
dafür lege ich sitz hier auf dem tablett
text sie mit einem sauberen geschirrtuch
ab und gibt sie noch mal in den warmen
ofen bei etwa 30 grad
die teil kugeln sind jetzt noch einmal
aufgegangen und jetzt direkt ausparken
in der pfanne ich habe zwei pfannen dann
geht es einfach ein bisschen schneller
ich werde das brot noch anrichten mit
etwas butter da habe ich 40 gramm und
ein paar chili schoten und ich werde
zuallererst mal die chips oben fallen
packen und zwar je nach eigenem
geschmack etwas schärfere oder etwas
mildere chilis so die möchte jetzt nicht
anfassen war später noch dna stillen und
wickeln und dann werden nicht so gut wie
an den händen hätte jetzt kann ich sie
beruhte formen und zwar macht ihr das am
besten mit den fingern so ein bisschen
auseinander ziehen und flach drücken
jetzt können die brote in einer pfanne
ohne fett geräumt werden und zwar lege
ich dies hier ein oder geht etwas
schneller
und sobald sie auf der unterseite braun
sind werden sie gewendet und sobald die
zweite seite auch gebräunt ist nämlich
direkt aus der pfanne und man sieht ja
auch direkt in unterschiedliche arbeit
nämlich hier einmal in einer reisen
pfanne da geht etwas schneller und
einmal in einer normal beschichteten
pfanne dauert etwas länger
die brote werden dann direkt von beiden
seiten mit der butter bestrichen und die
chili stückchen kann sich dann jeder
selber drauf legen
die brote sind jetzt fertig habe es
jetzt auch kurz abkühlen lassen
aber am besten so widmen sie jetzt
frisch bei uns jetzt gibt es gleich auch
eine hauptspeise mit dazu wo ihr könnt
ihr zum beispiel auch vorbereiten heißt
ihr könnt am abend den teig zubereiten
im kühlschrank gehen lassen und am
nächsten morgen dann in der pfanne
aussagen und habt ihr sogar vielleicht
so ein frühstück leckeres namen brot das
brot ist von der konsistenz her wirklich
sehr weichem locker also das sieht man
hier auch ganz gut
und statt der chili stücke können
natürlich auch andere geschmäcker mit
reinbringen zum beispiel frische kräuter
oder knoblauch würde auch ganz gut
passen
je nachdem wo es eben gereicht wird ich
habe hier noch mal die chili stücke in
die butter mit reihen gegeben damit der
geschmack alfred intensiver also falls
ihr dieses rezept nach machen wollt geht
auf meinem blog sallys - block der etat
steht noch mal ganz genau ich wünsche
euch auf jeden fall ganz viel spaß beim
nachhaken und wir sehen uns auch nicht
immer wieder abkühlt
macht das rezept nach und teil teuer
foto auch unserer facebook oder
instagram seite mit dem hashtag bmg
sally